Саакашвілі депортували.
Проте не його партію.
Принаймні це хочуть продемонструватиактивісти "Руху нових сил"
своїм невеличким флешмобом біля Адміністрації президента.
Ця акція– спроба відновити звичні при Саакашвілі
марші "За імпічмент Порошенка", яких не було вже майже 2 місяці.
Вони думають, що люди опустили руки,
і ніхтобільше протестуватине буде. Це не так….
Ольга Галабала- одна з чотирьох керівників ради "Руху нових сил".
Вона впевнено заявляє, щопісля депортації Саакашвілі
масового відтоку із партії не сталося.
Утім відсутність лідера відчувається, зізнається Ольга.
Це такий психологічний момент, що був Михайло, ніби він всіх штовхав вперед.
всі ми його бачили, як такий криголам,
який йде напролом, і всі ми йдемо за ним.
Зараз в нас , звичайно, змінилося потроху.
"Рух нових сил" активно готується до парламентських виборів 2019.
Партія намагається розширити діяльність в регіонах.
Нині існує 300 осередків, кажуть партійці.
Наше завдання зараз – це сформувати
5 мільйонів виборців "Руху нових сил"
через особистий контакт з ними
250000 ідейних і ідеологічних партійців "Руху нових сил".
Партійці сподіваються, що, потрапивши у владу,
вони зможуть повернути Саакашвілі в Україну.
Причому на посаду прем’єр-міністра.
Утім наразі, за даними різних соціологічних опитувань,
"Рух нових сил" має близько 1-го % довіри населення.
А отже - поки жодних шансів пройти в парламент.
Принаймні без об’єднання з потужнішою політичною силою,
вважають в представництві німецького фонду імені Фрідріха Еберта.
Директор представництва Марсель Ретіґ
до амбітних планів партії Саакашвілі ставиться дуже скептично.
Адже, вона ризикує залишитися партією на папері,
як і більшість з майже 340 зареєстрованих політичних сил в Україні,
які не мають ані продуманої програми,
ані стратегії, ані тим більше розвинутої структури,
адже створювалися під окремого політика.
Доки на чолі партії ця харизматична особистість, все може йти добре.
Але щойно харизматичний лідер зникає,
його не видно, він втрачає популярність тощо,
сиплеться уся партія, вся структура разом із ним.
Таке часто трапляється.
Партія ще далека від фіаско, вважають ії керівники.
Ольга Галабала демонструє DW статистику популярності сторінок партії
і ії керівників в соціальних мережах і стверджує,
що після депортації Саакашвілі
прихильників стало дещо більше.
Зараз, за її підрахунками, це майже півтора мільйона людей.
Проте в реальному світі- на вулицях Києва -
в потенціал "Руху нових сил" вірять геть не усі.
Це взагалі не партія якась, аавантюра!
Треба на виборах здобувати зміни,
а не такими вчинками.
Саакашвілі, звичайно, сильний політик.
Івін харизматичний. В нас таких других, як він, нема.
Але я думаю, що вони щось зроблять,
можливо вони справляться з цим.
Я вважаю, партія послабшала, у нього було достатньо енергії,
щоб усіх  організувати.
Це тільки одна назва залишилися,
нічого не залишилося.
"Рух нових сил" збирається відновити свої регулярнімарші
центром Києва і народні зібрання на вихідних.
Перший після двомісячноїперерви флешмоб "За відставку Порошенка"
відвідали щонайбільше дві сотні прихильників.
Ще півтора місяця тому акції протесту на чолі з Саакашвілі
збирали кілька тисяч людей на вулицях Києва.